so you've become the Elden Lord but
before you it was rigan and before him
it was Godfrey who items call the first
Elden Lord and yet even before Godfrey
there was another places ax an ancient
dragon who ruled as Elden Lord in the
Prehistoric Age before the ER tree it's
him and his kin that you're going to be
learning about in this video but to
quickly summarize first there were the
ancient Dragons Who had these Stone
scales that could twist time making them
essentially Immortal and yet some
ancient dragons can be found dead buried
in the rocks of faram maula which twists
and crumbles in an eternal storm on the
ground The Descendants roam the lands
between without the stone scales of
their ancestors and instead of stone
scales they've inherited aspects of
their environment the ice dragons roam
the icy mountaintops the glint stone
dragons feasted on sorcerers one's
hatred was so strong that he even
endured the Scarlet rot in kalid and
it's here in kalid that gray mother of
all the Mortal dragons lies dying
there's a lot to talk about this is the
story of Elden Rings
dragons many item descriptions note that
the age of the ancient dragons was
prehistoric and I think that's an
important word because it might explain
why Godfrey's recorded title is the
first Elden Lord even though he's not
places ax is the word prehistoric
denotes a period of time before written
history and while there are spoken
legends from this time I think what
they're trying to get across is that the
Elden Lord before Godfree wouldn't be
well known this was before the age of
the UR tree after all and the Earth tree
would eventually come to be considered
perfect and eternal so the idea that
there might have even been an Elden Lord
that came before could have been
considered irrelevant at best and
sacrilegious I think at worst but what
really is an Elden Lord and why was
places ax considered one I feel like the
role of Elden Lord can be roughly
narrowed down to three things you are
made eligible by a your strength B your
validity as a consort and or C your
willingness to bring about a new age or
order specifically the Elden Lord is
tasked with bringing about the greater
Wills order one built around the Elden
ring that had sent here long ago hence
the name Elden Lord sounds simple but
then remember the nature of the greater
Will's order can vary wildly as is shown
by all who come to Champion it over the
ages the greater Will's order is
malleable enough that it can even accept
a number of endings that out tarnished
brings about where the Elden ring is
mended by runes that will dramatically
redefine the world so it is that our
role as a tarnished is actually pretty
unique as our primary goal now is to
reunite the broken shards of the Elden
ring with America the god that is the
vessel of the Elden ring locked away
inside the earth tree it's not up to her
to will a new age into being it's up to
us and we have to gather the great runes
to do this so it is that in most endings
you ascend the throne as Elden Lord
alone without a God or living consort by
your side instead your crumbling God is
a vessel for your Elden ring and not
much more but previously it seems an
Elden Lord was chosen by their God
chosen for their strength chosen to sire
a lineage chosen for their usefulness to
their gods order so it was that hu was
chosen to be the Elden Lord as the age
of the UR tree began he defeated
marica's enemies he SED the golden
lineage and then was discarded in favor
of Radigan an Elden Lord who betrayed
marica's enemies and SED more demigod
children with her before being shattered
alongside his God
and since we don't actually know much
about places Sax's God we rely on horu
and rigan and America as well to teach
us the things that we should assume
would have been traditionally true about
her so it is that places Sax's God
likely chose him as Elden Lord because
places sax was powerful politically
expedient loyal and or perhaps a valid
consort and speaking of Elden Lords
being consorts it's certainly possible
that places ax consorted with his God
but I don't think that means that all or
any of the ancient dragons would have
been the result of that Union in fact as
noted by zulie the witch the heads of
places sa are different and are labeled
as male and female respectively so who's
to say places saacs didn't spawn their
own ancient dragons whatever the case
the ancient Dragons Were EX
exceptionally loyal to their lord and
multiple item descriptions state that
the ancient dragons who ruled in the
prehistoric era before the Earth tree
would protect their lord as a wall of
living Rock This is why the shape of the
Dragon has become symbolic of all manner
of protections and indeed we commonly
see dragons on Shields and on damage
reduction talismans but even without his
kin laying down their lives to protect
him places ax is in intensely powerful
in their own right in fact I'd say that
places sax was likely chosen as Elden
Lord for their strength in battle and
the physical evidence of battle is all
there their form is severely scarred and
even his heads have been severed in
unknown fights I think it's fair to
speculate that places saacs put their
life on the line for their God just as
Elden Lords would do for their gods in
years to come and just as his ancient
dragons did for him but what exactly is
an ancient dragon to help us distinguish
between all of the dragons in the game
it's important to note that not all
dragons in Elden ring are of the ancient
variety most are actually lesser wyen
like these though they're all descended
from the same stock ancient dragons
specifically are characterized by their
Mastery of red lightning as well as
their four wings four Limbs and stone
scales these Stone scales are perhaps
their most defining characteristic you
would have found these Stone scales in
your playthrough they would have been
looted as gravel Stones which are said
to be the scales of the ancient dragons
these gravel Stones can be used to craft
Dragon wound grease a weapon buff that
increases the damage you deal to dragons
it reads when the dragons were born from
their ancient kin they lost their Stone
scales which can now be used to cause
them mortal harm talk about insult to
injury so just like in Dark Souls it's
these Stone scales that gave the ancient
dragons their signature immortality and
as further evidence for that fact
consider the dragon King's Crag blade
which reveals that today's dual winged
two-legged dragons are considered
poultry and Mortal again confirming that
the ancient Dragons Were Immortal by way
of comparison but why are they Immortal
well the mechanism behind this
immortality is revealed by the ancient
dragon smithing Stones description which
marks it as a golden gravel stone and a
scale of the ancient dragon lord most
importantly though it reads this Stone
lightly twists time therefore it's
places Sax's very scales and likely also
those of his kin that have time-
twisting properties explaining the
ancient dragon's longevity it seems
they're immune to the effects of time
this also explains why places Sax's old
lords Talisman messes with time
lengthening the duration of sorceries
and incantations in the hands of the
tarnished most interesting though is
that the smithing Stone goes on to state
that it allows for the creation of a
weapon capable of slaying a god
presumably this is because of the
scale's time twisting abilities which I
theorize might help to sort of undo the
god that gets smacked with this from
existing in the first place maybe time
undoes them in that way or perhaps it
speeds up their eventual irrelevancy
over time it's really fitting that a God
would be weak to time and nothing else
really now scales twisting time is one
thing but all of foua seems to exist
outside of time to some extent there is
no day and night cycle here for example
and this time twisting effect is
particularly strong in plac Sax's Arena
which you access by lying down at the
very edge of his storm in a way you kind
of become a part of the environment here
in this moment as the space you're lying
in is actually a shallow grave meant for
in tment it's just missing a skeleton
whereas the other Graves have them and
now that you're part of Fula itself time
stops then actually begins to bring you
backwards in in time with the repairing
ruins to places Sax's Forum where the
dragon lord once dwelled eternally
Beyond time so time is extremely
convoluted in plac Sax's Arena and I say
this because it's here in the heart of
the storm Beyond time that you're able
to use an item called micha's needle
which is one of the unalloyed gold
needles that Mika crafted to Ward away
the meddling of outer gods
now currently this needle is only a
temporary solution it only Wards off the
outer God's influence it doesn't cure
one of it as Melania is evidence of
indeed the final Silver version of the
needle reveals that the needle is still
as yet unfinished and can only be used
in the heart of the storm Beyond Time
said to be found in faram maula it's
here alone that the needle does finally
function f fully removing the entire
influence of the outer God in your body
Mika originally intended to use this
needle to repel the outer God of rot
within his sister but here if you're
locked into the Lord of frenzied flame
ending you can use the needle to cheat
fate and undo the frenzy God's influence
Instead This reveals that the final
missing component of the needle is time
it just needs this final time twisting
effect to be complete so as with the
smithing Stones we just mentioned
perhaps you are inserting the needle at
a point before the outer God's influence
existed upon you or perhaps the gods are
simply again weak to 's effects I wonder
if Mika knew this I wonder if he knew
that time twisting was what was needed
to complete the needle and I wonder if
he even realized that this is a place
you could come to do that
anyway the one weird thing about micha's
needle is that you can use it in plac
Sax's Arena even though he's dead
raising the question you know hang on if
it's plac Sax's scales that twist time
why is it time is being Twisted here in
a location even without him and his
scales present now I do have a theory
that might reconcile this issue remember
how I brought up the time only starts
moving backwards when you lie down in a
burial space and become a part of the
environment well my theory is that what
if it's the land mass of Fula itself
that also twists time I think it might
be able to do this because the land mass
literally has ancient dragons and their
time twisting scales in tuned within it
the official art book reveals a ton of
these ancient dragons and indeed ancient
dragons can be found within farama
zula's geological stratum I asked data
Miner zulli the witch to take a closer
look at these assets and she discovered
that there are two variants of these
inomed dragons that show up here here
here and here so four dragons in total
that we can see at least at first I
thought that these might represent
places A's missing heads but the intact
variant of the model displays four wings
and four legs meaning these were entire
ancient dragons that said they don't
look entirely like ancient dragons in
fact their heads are actually the same
as plac axes albeit rendered in a lower
level of detail so personally given the
information I have I believe that this
suggests that these intuned dragons
might be plac Sax's Offspring or kin
perhaps even an older generation of
ancient dragon in tuned in a previous
geological stratum of faram moua's
ancient history so it is that I think
you can argue that the land mass of Fula
itself can twist time but additionally
or alternatively fara's storm itself
might represent this time twisting
micha's needle does say that it can only
be used in the heart of the storm in
Fula so perhaps Sax's golden scales sort
of Twisted a storm into being and maybe
that storm twists time irrespective of
whether places ax is alive or not also I
really like the idea that twisting
storms are a visual representation of
the scales that twist time because the
scales do specifically use the word
twist in regards to time so the storm
and these twisting hurricanes are so
perfect VIs visually for that but as we
move into the next chapter I want to
point out one more interesting thing
about these golden scales and it's that
according to their item descriptions
they're only made into stones after
being polished and thanks to their older
item description text in version 1.0 of
Elden ring we know exactly who it was
that polished these stones in the first
place they were refined by sentient
beasts that regarded them as holy relics
so it is that we arrive at the beastmen
of faram maula who were the ancient
dragons clergymen worshippers and
lessers there are a few types of
beastmen in faram maula but most wield
their signature curved sword a weapon
that is forged from dull iron but is so
welld designed that despite its weight
it it's comparatively easy to wield for
the damage it delivers this skill in
smithing seems to extend to their Throne
weapons as well which Boomerang through
the air towards you like nothing else in
the lands between as the Beast Man
Cleaver itself States it's clear the
beastmen possess knowledge Beyond human
Ken as you start to progress towards the
latter half of Fula you'll start to be
assailed by red lightning wielded by the
beastman CL
some Warriors even carry weapons blessed
with its effects this is significant
because red lightning is explicitly
called the weapon wielded by the ancient
dragons lightning in from software games
has always been a weapon of divinity and
those that wield it are naturally the
Blessed adherence of that Divinity in
this case the divines with the ancient
Dragons Who wielded this lightning
within the storms of Fula so for the
beastmen to wield it the art was
probably taught to them for additional
context one of the only other characters
who wields a weapon imbued with red
lightning is vik a tarnished beloved by
an ancient dragon indeed certain
beastmen were quote unquote chosen or
blessed in a similar way with the isula
Beast Man Spirit ashes stating that
fara's giant mosum was guarded by chosen
beastmen who wield weapons clad in
lightning
for more evidence of the Beast men's
reverence of ancient dragons we can look
to the five SES of Grace in Fula that
Mark different sections of the Dragon
Temple a sprawling place of worship that
features multiple statues of Beast
clergymen bent in reverence towards
ancient dragon statues and the central
part of the Dragon Temple is this the
place where you would have fought the
godkin duo an altar overshadowed by an
enor ormous dragon skeleton for
reference these skeletal remains dwarf
even places saacs and are matched only
in size by the dragon gra and the
ancient dragon grx both of whom we'll
discuss a little bit later the aula
beastman spirit ashes state that faram
aula is said to be the remains of a
giant mosum enshrining an ancient dragon
and given this dragon's prominent
placement in the Dragon Temple of all
places I actually think the Ed dragon in
question might be this one though you
could certainly make the argument that
the enshrined ancient dragon was places
ax instead but regardless of exactly
what it's entr trining Fula really is
just a huge mosum with burial Customs
literally around every corner
considering all the jars in this place
one such type of burial that comes to to
mind is jar burial a practice documented
in ancient human cultures all across the
globe now this practice would show up
more explicitly later in Olden Ring's
timeline with the living jars which are
literally filled with the interred
remains of powerful warriors but beyond
the powerful ferary imagery in Fula
there's actually no explicit evidence
that I can find that suggests actual
inment Within These jars in contrast the
Beast man's jar Shield is quite clear
that the beastmen have always fired earn
wear jars for the express purpose of
making Shields the description comments
that these ways are strange and I feel
like I can offer a strange Theory here
we know that the beastmen value Golden
Stone scales right and we know that
there are literally ancient dragons
inomed within the Earth of Fula so what
if the beastmen value the dragon infused
Earth for this reason firing pots from
this Dragon Earth in an initial barrial
custom then breaking them to use as
sacred Shields we established earlier
that the golden scaled ancient dragons
are a symbol of protection and
considering these are earn wear Shields
that are flecked with the same golden
hue as their scales I feel like this
theory is all right it's the the only
way I can rationalize making Shields out
of pots that are made out of Earth
anyway a somewhat predictably the
beastmen practice in tement of their own
species as well and I'm not just talking
about their gold adorned tombs I'm
talking about their inment in the
architecture itself as well the skeletal
remains of the beastmen frequently show
up within the architecture of verula
itself this reminds me of the the
historical practice of immurement which
was this sort of horrific form of
capital punishment usually where the
subject was entombed in a structure
while alive that said there are
historical examples of immurement being
more about human sacrifice a part of a
grand burial ceremony In some cultures
and believed to make buildings sturdier
in others and I feel like it would have
been the beastmen who built the
architecture of Fula not the dragons
themselves it is structured to be a
melum after all and since it's the
beastmen who Revere the ancient Dragons
It's naturally the beastmen who would
have occupied the labor roles in society
that said I guess humans also could have
built it since humans are depicted in
the architectural reliefs of Fula so it
stands to reason that humans were a part
of this culture as well even at this
early prehistoric period of time which
is kind of crazy considering how much
humans contrast with the beastmen here
as with a lot of the architecture in
from software games I feel like it would
be a bit dishonest of me not to mention
that these in particular are reused
assets also present in bloodborne so
it's possible that from software didn't
expect us to read into these assets too
hard but let's give them the benefit of
the doubt and assumed that they at least
wanted to suggest that there was a human
presence in Fula once so not only were
humans present but they were worthy of
being enshrined who were they well our
biggest clues about different types of
humans comes from origin text in the
character creation screen and there are
two human types in particular that I
think might be a match for the humans in
these reliefs first are the Newman the
Newman are supposed descendants of Denis
of another world and the Newman's Rune
tells us that the Newman are said to
have come from outside the lands between
considering faram maula experienced a
cultural revolution with the coming of
the greater will and the Elden ring
which arrived upon an extraterrestrial
star I wouldn't be surprised if humanoid
humans came along for the ride as well
alternatively the character creator
reveals law for the Stony face of the
people of the ancient dragons among whom
life is typically short it certainly
seems to be suggesting that these humans
are descended from the ancient dragons
why else would it note their Stony faces
or their short lives in contrast to the
Ancients as we'll discover later ancient
dragons can turn into humans so perhaps
they intermingled at some point in the
past to to create these humans that said
this is all just speculation and a human
presence on Fula is otherwise quite hard
to process considering the beasts are
clearly the legacy of faram maula for it
was the beasts who would gain
intelligence and shape the world around
them not
humans ancient historians have long
speculated that it was the development
of long opposable thumbs that helped
facilitate early humans use of tools
similarly in Olden ring having five
fingers is something to be celebrated as
is revealed by the cadea a weapon of the
Beast clergyman this item description is
one of those ones that is just hugely
significant for the law the name cadea
means five fingers and it visually shows
five skeletal fingers on the blade the
item description goes on to state that
the design celebrates a beast five
fingers symbolic of the intelligence
once granted upon their kind so before
there were beastmen there were simply
beasts here and it was the bestowal of
intelligence which is equated with
having five fingers that led to the
Beast men this of course begs the
question who or what bestowed
intelligence upon the beastmen and
luckily it's a simple one to answer it
was the greater will the greater will is
all about fingers it speaks through the
two fingers it hates if you have three
fingers it will tolerate four fingers
but five is the amount to be celebrated
or at least it was long ago and if this
veneration of fingers wasn't enough
evidence for you well the 1.0 version of
the cadea literally states that it was
the greater will who granted the beasts
intelligence so that's that the greater
will clearly also has a bit of a thing
for acting through beasts just look at
the final boss it's an Elden Beast one
that the greater will sent hurtling into
the lands between so that it could later
become the Elden ring and in this
prehistoric period the ancient dragons
would be graced by the greater will
first with the beastmen later being
granted intelligence as well all the
better to Revere the ancient dragons
with according to beastial incantations
Stones were the first weapons of the
beasts who had gained intelligence and
having gained intelligence the beasts
must have felt how their wildness
slipped away as civilization took hold
of course this is yet another example
where the greater will takes away
wildness or chaos in favor of order it
seems to care little what form that
order takes it only cares that some
order takes hold preferably taking hold
with a full five fingered fist in game
the five-fingered cadea is wielded by
gank the Beast clergyman according to
the weapon it is only given to high
ranking clergyman of razula marking gank
as one of their number presumably this
means he is or was a clergyman of the
ancient dragon Faith before being
repurposed by the greater will but
becoming a shadow for America instead
after all when we encounter him in game
the age of the ancient dragons has long
past yet he still achieves relevancy in
this age in yet another subservient role
as is common to all beasts except this
time it's to Marica and this time he is
a shadow of the Imperium which is a
topic we should touch on
next
we first meet grank at the beastial
sanctum a place in kalid that bears a
striking resemblance to faram maula
there's even a bridge down the way
called farum Great Bridge with a dragon
defending it no less these are no mere
ruins that have fallen from the sky this
architecture is intact and must have
been built for and by the beasts at some
point after they received intelligence
we'll get into that point a little bit
later but for now let's focus on gank we
first learn about gank from his beastial
incantations which are given to us when
we hand him death rout they read long
ago grank was a beast of such terrifying
ferocity that his former name meant
death of the demigods this former name
in question was malth a new name to suit
his new purpose which was to seal away
the ruin of destined death for America
who was his imperion so first he was
gank then as the age of the ancient
dragons ended and Marica became a force
in the world grank became known as malth
instead who was and I quote a
shadowbound beast given to his Imperium
who was Mara Mar had one job for malth
and that was to lock away destined death
to a degree he fails at this task and a
fragment of of destined death is stolen
becoming the death route that spreads
throughout the lands so it is that gank
has returned to the lands between now
trying desperately to scrape together
all the Death route in the world the
Beast claw incantation talks about his
present identity as this spell
represents the fury of grank his
beastial nature returned as much as it
does his Restless agitation but after
realizing his mission is impossible
grank pieces out and then we're only
able to find him in one place alone
faram maula where he has ascended with a
draconic tree Sentinel as his Defender
here he sort of exists outside of time
defending what remains of destined death
within his very own flesh it's easy to
get confused about when gank exists in
the game so apologies for skipping over
this topic quickly but this video is
about dragons after all and the main
thing I really want to get across here
is just how much the beasts have been
repurposed to suit the needs of the
greater will first it gave them
intelligence and then they served the
ancient dragon order but then when the
ancient Dragon's Age ended beasts like
gank were given new purpose commonly as
shadowbound entities compelled to serve
order once more whatever form their
Imperium dictated that order should take
the Raging wolf set states that
according to the old Legends wolves are
the Shadows of the Imperium it's
certainly possible that this Legend
originated in faram maula there is after
all a statue that features three wolves
deferring to a human woman it might be a
stretch to assume that this is depicting
wolves as Shadows of the imperion but I
thought I'd mention it at least again in
case you've forgotten an imperion is
basically Al one of the greater Will's
candidates for godhood and in Marica and
rani's case at least they were granted
wolves as their Shadows wolves who
evolved to be man's best friend as they
say are defined as such because of their
loyalty and as stated by the Beast
Champion Helm the beasts their eyes and
ears covered represent an oath see
nothing hear nothing doubt nothing and
carry on along the path set in stone and
so it is that grank and blly are wolves
completely loyal to their imperian
dedicated to protecting their Lords just
like the ancient dragons of old this
loyalty to the greater will and also
their Imperium causes this fantastic
tension within these characters in the
case of grank he was loyal to America
but now lives impatiently with this
impossible task task of having to
recover every piece of death route and
in the case of blly his loyalty to Rani
eventually forces him to betray the two
fingers in complete Defiance of the Fate
that he was born to speaking of which
blly is quite unique from gank unlike
gank he has no apparent ties to faram
maula after all unlike gank he was
created to be Ran's imperian and grew up
with her in a more Modern Age that was
far removed from fulas perhaps this is
why blly takes on a much more human form
blly was created in a much more Modern
Age than the beasts of old so it seems
the two fingers skipped a lot of the
history and simply created blly in a
more halfman image creating him from
scratch as opposed to his forbears the
other Beast worth mentioning here is SOS
the Ethereal Beast Regent given to
Godfrey to weigh down his ceaseless lust
for Battle of course Godfrey is Elden
Lord not an imperion just so SOS is not
a wolf but a lion like grank he has a
longer history and according to the
Beast claw great hammer he was at one
point a lord of beasts with black nails
protruding from Golden fur to quote the
champion set beasts are drawn to
Champions and to Lords and and this
holds true for the Beast men drawn to
SOS and in the future it would hold true
for SOS himself a beast that became Lord
Godfrey's Regent intended to guide him
and his golden lineage so sash was drawn
to Godfrey as well but no matter who the
beasts were loyal to whether it was to
their Beast Lords or to the ancient
dragons or then Elden Lords or Imperium
throughout all of this they were always
following a deeper loyalty a loyalty to
the greater will and its ancient Elden
ring this Elden ring looks very
different for one it appears to have
many more circlets many more great runes
than the modern Elden ring considering
its placement in faram maula a place
from long ago I speculate that this is
an ancient variant of the Elden ring a
depiction of it back during the era of
the ancient dragons what's more this
ancient Elden ring has what appear to be
Roots snaking down and descending from
it this is in contrast to the modern
Elden ring which has this ltis pattern
instead the lattice pattern is most
commonly seen as a symbol of Radigan
an Elden Rune that is visible on his
statues and his scar seal as well I
always thought that the lsted pattern
might represent rigan's efforts to sort
of Stitch the Elden ring back together
when it was shattered and we'll
speculate on what the roots might mean a
little bit later as well as for why the
Elden ring looks different though well
it makes sense that the olden ring would
have changed throughout the ages we know
the thing is malleable after all there
are examples of runes being taken out of
it and put back into it depending on the
specific needs of the God who acts as a
vessel for its power or the needs of the
tarnished who will become Elden Lord via
great runes or even via mending runes
The Vessel of the Elden ring we know in
the modern era is America she literally
has the Elden ring inomed within her but
back in the age before the UR tree the
goldon ring would have had a different
vessel a different God and unfortunately
all we know about them is that they
abandoned pesx who was their Elden Lord
the remembrance of the Dragon Lord reads
the dragon lord whose seat lies at the
heart of the storm Beyond time is said
to have been Elden Lord in the age
before the UR Trey once his God was fled
the Lord continued to await its return
I'm assuming assuming that his God had a
female aspect considering all the other
imperion and gods in Elden ring do so it
is that when we find places sax he is in
a state of Eternal
maiden and who knows how long places ax
has been waiting for his God to return
in fact one Community Theory I love that
have seen put forward a few times is
that places Sax's pose is similar to
that of the two fingers after you were
rejected by the Earth Tree in case you
forgot it's at this stage that enia says
the two fingers have taken up this pose
because they're busy Consulting with the
greater will just so the same might be
true of places sax who has also been
spurned by his God and the greater will
and is trying perhaps to commune with
them to take this analogy further places
sax has two heads now now but data
recently uncovered by zulie the witch
suggests that he once had five not
unlike how the two fingers assumedly
once came from a full five-fingered hand
that said the old Lord's Talisman
depicts biax with foreheads to reconcile
this contradiction maybe we can just
think that he had four heads when this
Talisman was made perhaps anyway not a
big deal what is a big deal is places
axes
who represents this huge blind spot for
us in Elden Ring's law we don't know who
they were we don't know what powers they
had and we don't know when or why they
left or what age they really wanted to
bring about as such I'll be calling them
the nameless God from this point
forwards whoever they were all we know
for certain is that they once saw pesx
as a valid Elden Lord so they might have
been all about the age of the ancient
dragons once however I feel like it says
more about this God that they fled this
age and abandoned their loyal Elden Lord
this reminds me a lot of what Amica did
to her Elden Lord Godfrey exiling and
abandoning him after he had won her Wars
and outlived his usefulness though at
least with Godfrey Marica had a secret
plan for her Lord and his tarnished kin
to return on the other hand bisx was
abandoned and has waited for an eternity
only to die at the hands of our
tarnished so whoever his God was I feel
like they really did abandon him
entirely the greater Will's gods are the
vessels of the Elden ring and places
Sax's nameless God jumping ship with the
olden ring would have surely represented
an enormous upheaval to what became
crumbling
Fula speaking of which I still haven't
really explained how it became crumbling
Fula many descriptions state that Fula
has been crumbling since time immemorial
and it's for this reason that you can
find tiny ruin fragments and enormous
ones too scattered all over the lands
between this is better explained by the
description of of one such ruin fragment
which was honed into a weapon called The
Ruins Greatsword this is one of the
legendary armaments originally rubble
from a ruin which fell from the sky the
ruin it came from crumbled when struck
by a meteorite as such this weapon
Harbors its destructive power so
meteorites with destructive power are
these purple spells in Olden ring and
indeed this weapon skill is waves of
Destruction which manifests as purple
energy so a meteorite crashed into Fula
and that meteorite was purple and imbued
the ruins with sort of gravitational
magic but beyond that there's not really
much we know about this meteorite we
don't even know if it struck for amula
when it was a city on the ground lifting
the city into the sky with gravitational
man magc or if it struck for amula while
it was already skybound crashing into
the city while it was in midair so much
of fara's history is hidden from us this
meteorite might even be the same
meteorite as others mentioned in Elden
Ring's law because lots of meteorites
have made landfall in the lands between
before some brought the Onyx Lords a
race of ancients with skin of stone Who
Rose to life when a meteor struck a
creature called a stelle may have
brought himself down on a meteorite and
destroyed an entire Eternal City a
golden star even once bore the Elden
Beast and the Elden ring into the lands
between in the first place thus you
could speculate that any one of these or
even a different one entirely laid waste
to faram maula again you could even
speculate that it was this meteor that
imbued fara's ruins with gravitational
energy lifting it into the sky not
unlike how the Earth in Lim grave is
lifted into the sky after being hit by a
meteorite and so perhaps similarly
fara's world was lifted higher into the
sky twisting in place also thanks to the
stone scales of the ancient dragons
whatever the case as Fula crumbled and
twisted in the sky ruined fragments rain
down upon the entire lands between some
large and some small incidentally these
ruined fragments glow with a faint light
from within and are conducive to
Blessings from the two and three fingers
respectively that's what warming stones
and frenzy flame stones are they are
pieces of Ruin fragments imbued with
Power and Light and this makes a lot of
sense because these ruins are a part of
the Royal City that the greater will
itself once graced so naturally parts of
its ruins are very conducive to the
effects of the two and three fingers
anyway we don't know many other details
behind fara's ruin but whatever the case
it's probably fair to say that this
meteorite dealt an enormous blow to
their culture it might have even
coincided with their God fleeing the
city and whenever this nameless God
did leave I think it's important to
speculate on where they went
[Music]
next after the age of the Dragon Lord
the age of the Earth tree began but
before the age of the Earth tree began
we learned that there was first a
crucible of Life a primordial Crucible
where all life was once Blended together
according to sala's Crucible tree Helm
this Crucible was the primordial form of
the earth tree a manifestation of the
earth tree's Primal vital energies so
over the next few minutes I'm going to
try and argue that The Crucible became
rooted quite literally quite physically
in the great tree roots that we find
underneath the lands between I don't
think it's a coincidence that the
ancient Elden ring of Fula is burgeoning
with roots and after faram maula's age
ended and its God absconded with an
Elden ring that is burgeoning with roots
I don't think it's a coincidence that a
primordial Crucible gave way to a great
tree that would dominate the lands
between I think the Elden ring
physically left for amaza I think that
led to The Crucible which led to Great
tree roots which led to the Earth tree
growing the Elden ring is after after
all the source of the her tree and this
should have been true for the ancient
Elden ring as well which would have
birthed this tree as an additional piece
of evidence that the Elden ring is at
the source of the ER tree we can look at
the engraving on the stone door of the
earth tree itself which shows the Elden
ring literally at the roots of the earth
tree its source below the surface
perhaps the Elden ring wasn't rooted in
the earth while farul was floating up in
the sky but eventually it seems it would
be according to the Gilded great shield
and ova's great sword the color of the
her trees primordial Crucible was red or
perhaps more accurately red tinged with
gold the red tinge in the gold coat
mirrors the primordial matter that
became the ER tree the color of hward
Yearning its red tint exemplifies the
nature of primordial gold said to be
close in nature to life itself this
color is also seen in root resin a
secretion from Roots that were once
connected to the great tree these two
items taken together tie the red of The
Crucible to Great tree roots quite well
and if that wasn't enough Crucible night
salura spends her Exile amidst these
roots with a spear and a Helm that have
great tree ornamentation that is modeled
on The Crucible I've seen people
speculate that The Crucible isn't a
physical place and that it was just a
crucible of competition instead where
different creatures battled against each
other and I think this misconception
might be due to the original description
of the old Fang in version 1.0 of Elden
ring which reads in times long past life
was a crucible of competition however
the item description was quickly patched
to remove all mention of competition and
the patched description instead suggests
that multiple overlapping fangs might be
a vestage of the primordial Crucible so
considering this updated description and
all of the color and mention of
primordial matter I think fromsoft are
certainly trying to suggest that The
Crucible had a real physicality to it
and The Crucible has long been a topic
plagued by confusing and perhaps
mistranslated item descriptions take the
aspects of The Crucible which say that
The Crucible was once a place where all
life was once Blended together the
Japanese instead clarifies that once
life was Blended together which to me
suggests The Crucible was a blending of
existing life in the lands between
rather than a source of all life and I
think there's more evidence that this
ancient Elden ring of Fula was already
kind of laying the groundwork for The
Crucible for example we know from The
Omen and Mis begotten that creatures of
The Crucible are characterized by
chaotic growth considered aspects of
devolution in the modern era these are
aspects of wings horns scales feathers
and fangs just so places ax actually has
tons of random Fang growths around their
MO and later dragons even Sprout
feathers another aspect of devolution
but if that wasn't enough remember the
dragon's lightning is red tinted with
gold as well which is the same color of
the primordial Crucible as we just
discussed thus I think it's safe to say
that the color and other aspects of the
primordial Crucible were already kind of
present in the ancient dragons the old
of those graced by the Elden ring that
we know of so with that we've
essentially laid the groundwork for a
theory that I'd like to shout out from
Loki who is one of from software's most
dedicated Theory Crafters in this theory
he speculates on the identity of the
Dragon Lord's fled God and I think this
theory is special because it manages to
reconcile a couple of major loose ends
in the game's law along the way as the
theory goes the Earth tree was created
as a byproduct of the nameless God's
death Loki's initial reasoning is that
after we die runes are left behind in
our wake manifesting as small golden
saplings therefore since the Elden ring
itself is made up of a gargantuan amount
of runes surely the Elden ring would
sprout an enormous tree if the god
vessel carrying it were to die one thing
I'll add to this theory is that our
golden saplings only remain so if the
mass of runes is not claimed just so if
no one knew that the nameless God had
died perhaps the Elden Ring's mass of
runes was left to its own devices to
grow as Loki posits as a resilient
protective vessel a firmly rooted tree
that wel WTH no man and indeed the
nameless God did flee not even telling
her Elden Lord places sax where they had
gone thus their runes might have gone
unclaimed directly below the Earth tree
are the deep root depths where the Earth
tree might have once been planted so to
speak and one of the Lesser known paths
along the roots here leads to this wall
an illus wall that reveals the cathedral
of The Forsaken the frenzied merchants
and the three fingers of frenzy one of
the strangest items down here is the
fingerprint Stone Shield which is and I
quote part of the tomb of an ancient god
it's imprinted with an intricately
carved fingerprint design and these
imprints are said to be the very seeds
from which frenzy first sprouted now at
first glance you'd think that the
ancient god in question here here would
be the three fingers who marked this
great stone slab with fingerprints and
while I admit this Stone grave could be
for the outer God of frenzied flame
which manifests as the three fingers who
are imprisoned down here I much prefer
the theory that this stone slab was the
tomb of a different ancient god one that
was found and desecrated by the three
fingers with their fingerprints just as
they desecrate the world with
fingerprints in their ending and that's
exactly what Loki's theory proposes that
the three fingers desecrated a stone
Tomb of the nameless God places A's
Queen who had her final moments in this
place the nameless God can also be used
to reconcile another L Gap in Elden ring
which is the identity of the corpse that
makes up the Finger Slayer Blade the
Finger Slayer blade is a blade said to
have been born of a corpse said to be
able to harm the greater will and its
vassals the two fingers the shape of
this blade featuring The Arms Of A
corpse as a cross guard and culminating
in a double helix it Bears a striking
resemblance to the sacred Relic sword a
weapon wrenched from the corpse of
Radigan Marica the sacred Relic sword is
and I quote wrought from the remains of
a God who should have lived a life
eternal the similarities between the
sacred Relic Sword and the Finger Slayer
blade mean that they must have shared a
source not just a corpse but the corpse
of a God we know where the sacred Relic
sword comes from it comes from rigan and
America but then where does the Finger
Slayer blade come from if it's wrought
from a god it's a nameless God as far as
we know so it is that Loki concludes
that the nox who made a hidden treasure
of the blade may have recovered the
corpse of plac Sax's Queen the nameless
God to wield as a weapon that could harm
the great a will so I like these
theories to say the least they neatly
tie up and reconcile a bunch of loose
ends and that makes these theories
really satisfying to believe it's nice
to have an explanation for which God the
Finger Slayer blade was talking about
and which ancient god the fingerprint
Stone Shield was talking about special
thanks to Loki for this you can find
more of his stuff in the description and
I highly recommend you seek it out
however I should probably stress that
this is still all speculation the
circumstantial evidence is really strong
yes but sometimes from software leaves
these sorts of loose ends in the law to
be tied up by characters that they've
yet to introduce and until DLC drops I
think it's wise to take this Theory with
a grain of salt but damn you know salt
makes any meal taste a little bit better
doesn't
it so it is that the nameless God of
Fula might have become the nox's Finger
Slayer blade a weapon they clearly
brought about in order to harm the
greater will which had banished them
deep underground beneath the false night
sky you can learn more about that in
this video here they live in Eternal
anticipation of the coming age of stars
and their leash who would be a lord of
KN these folk become obsessed with
artificial Imitation of Life above
ground all likely created in service of
their goal which was to strike back at
the greater will so it was that the
mimic tear were created these are beings
of quicksilver that were the result of
an attempt attt by the Eternal City to
forge a lord these silver drops of Jew
not unlike the her trees drops of duw
they also birthed the Alban orics who
are artificial life forms Untouched by
the Earth tree's Grace but the KNX also
looked further back in time for
inspiration apparently and they
attempted to bring ancient dragons into
being so it is that the dragonkin
soldiers were born in the Eternal City
where they knew no true sky nor true
lightning their name includes the word
Soldier and they even have evidence of
clothing and armor upon them again
revealing that these creatures were
created with the intention to fight back
against order but these dragonkin
experiments went about as well as
copying dragons usually does in from
software games which is to say the
experiments were a fail failure the main
reason they were considered failures was
that these Dragon Kin were not Immortal
as the KNX had hoped their weapons read
alas the dragonking soldiers never
attained immortality and perished as
decrepit pale imitations of their
skyborn kin but the KNX had the right
idea at the very least it seems they had
identified the source of the ancient
dragons immortality their Stone scales
they just failed to implement that
Source case in point the dragon scale
blade is made by sharpening a gravel
Stone scale thought to be the source of
dragon immortality this Blade's skill is
ice lightning sword which wreaths the
blade in the dragon kin's signature ice
lightning and you know even though the
Dragon Kin were born mortal and crippled
they did at least manage to manifest
lightning
which is a feat that the Mortal dragons
who were actually the ancient dragons
kin never
accomplished on your way through kalid
you would have run past gra a mortal
Dragon who clearly owes their name sake
to grol a veritable Mountain found
further down the way where she lies
dying surrounded by her children on her
deathbed but these aren't her only
children according to gr's Roar grol was
the mother of all dragons dwarfing all
who stood before her like a looming
Mountain to be clear I seriously doubt
this means that she's the mother of the
ancient dragons considering she has two
Wings two legs and no stone scales no
instead she would specifically be the
mother of the two-winged dragons that
you see widely across the lands between
indeed the Japanese specifies that she's
more of a great mother of dragons rather
than being mother of all dragons so if
we take that premise to be true that
means that the fire breathing dragons
the ice dragons the rot and glint Stone
corrupted dragons all of them Trace
their ancestry back to Grail these are
the wyvn contrasting with the true
four-legged dragons which is the same
Dynamic that Dark Souls had as well and
just like in Dark Souls Elden Rings
dragons have a tendency to take on
aspects of their environment in lie of
their Stone scales there are ice dragons
there are Glenstone dragons all of that
but the one element that these dragons
didn't Master though is lightning red
lightning that remains exclusive to
their ancient ancestors earlier we
talked about how lightning has Heavenly
connotations and it makes sense that
this lightning would be lost to these
lesser dragons who were born in a Time
long after the ancient dragons had sort
of lost the favor of the greater will
these modern dragons are now easily
wounded by the stone scales that they've
lost these Stone scales once removed are
called gravel stones and these are
compound stones that are found in lands
once beset by ancient dragons for the
most part these gravel stones are looted
upon the Altus plateau and surrounds
which makes sense because this is the
territory of lell the city that the
ancient dragons would eventually assault
so of course this is where their scales
would be found but interestingly the
only other place where gravel stones are
found is kalid and that's curious
because kalid is literally at the
opposite end of the lands between one
set of gravel stones are found here and
here suggesting that at some point the
ancient dragons progenitors de grol were
in kalid as well and this fact is
supported by other environmental
evidence in the area again the beastial
sanctum and fum greatbridge are in kalid
two cultural landmarks of Fula that are
architecturally intact despite the
crumbling Ci's current state these
weren't just ruins that fell from the
sky these were built they are a grounded
connection to what we now know as a Sky
City while I guess we can't rule out the
possibility that Fula was always in the
sky and later built architecture on the
ground here it seems way more natural to
assume that the city was originally
built on the ground where there would
have been the materials to build it and
that it was then lifted into the sky at
some point in the future as for the
mechanism behind for amaza becoming
skybound I feel like there are two
options earlier we talked about how the
ruins great sword is a piece of Fula
infused with gravitational magic thanks
to the meteor that struck the city thus
my first theory is that faram maula
might have become skybound in the
instant that the meteor struck floating
upward as it was destroyed alternatively
or additionally I guess it could be some
manifestation of the storm that brought
faram maula into the sky we've talked
about how places ax might have had power
over this storm evidenced by his golden
time twisting scales not to mention you
turn into a storm cloud when you Channel
places Sax's weapon skill so perhaps
places ax or the ancient dragons whipped
Fula into the skies as some measure of
protection and once it was up there that
gravitational meteor could have come
into play Smashing the city into pieces
on its way down to the lands between
scattering ruins far and wide at any
rate I'm glad there's evidence of foua
here in kalid and that's because this
fact merges so well with the law of
Graal again gry is the mother of the
modern dragons and thus is the oldest
modern dragon that we know of who lost
their Stone scales and since she's in
kalid it was likely from here that all
dragons spread so I'm glad the
environment supports this law with its
intact for araza architecture and with
the leftover gravel stones of the
ancient dragons as well because it seems
like the ancient dragons made landfall
here long ago and started a culture in
Fula leaving gryal behind eventually as
their land bound Legacy and there are
two other ancient dragons in the
vicinity to help support this claim as
well these ancient dragons appear here
in Lim grave and here in kalid both dead
at the sights of dragon communion the
ancient dragons are Immortal but they
can still be killed as you know though
we can only really speculate on what
killed these two but back to grol
despite being a modern dragon gry is
large larger than any other Dragon of
the time even placc in fact the only
thing that comes close close to her in
size are grxs and the bones of the
dragon in farama zula's dragon Temple
which zulli has thankfully placed
alongside grail for me they're both very
similar in size which made me think that
maybe they could have been mates at some
point though of course that's just
speculation and in the end we don't even
know why Gro lost all of her Stone
scales passing this trait to all of her
descendants perhaps it was nothing more
than a random birth defect which reminds
me se's loss of stone scales was never
really explained either yet he also
found himself apart from his ancient kin
all the same perhaps this is why gryal
found herself in the lands between was
this a place of Exile maybe a place to
die her region is called Dragon Barrow
after all and if you've read Lord of the
Rings for example you might take the
meaning of the word barrow to mean
burial mounds referring to ancient
burial places that are covered with
large mounts of Earth perhaps the dragon
Barrow was a place for these newly
mortal dragons to die and gra herself is
indeed now finally dying the Scarlet rot
has blighted kalid and the dragon Barrow
and this is presumably why when we
encounter her she's already lost a lot
of her health and she can't fight back
nor or even lift herself off the ground
her dying Roars rally her kin around her
but they cannot save their mother this
level one tarnished just watched this
sick YouTube guide on how to get 50,000
free runes at the start of the game and
nothing will stand in their
way now we previously established kalid
and gry at as a sort of origin point for
the modern dragons so after them in the
timeline I think it's the ice dragons
that would have shown up as the first
major variant according to Borealis is
Mist the ice dragons were once Lords of
the mountaintops perhaps these dragons
wished to be as close as possible to the
heavens from which their ancestors
descended after all we do see the modern
dragons flying all around far amula
though they never make land for
so the mountain tops might have been the
next best thing as a home for the Mortal
dragons after all the sword of night and
Flame claims that the mountaintops
nearly touched the sky anyway Borealis
as Mist goes on to reveal that the ice
dragons were Lords here at a very early
point in the lands between history as
shortly after we know that they were
chased from the peak by the fire Giants
who also appeared at a very early point
and who claimed the mountaintops
henceforth so for the ice dragons to be
here you'd think surely they must have
migrated here from kalid now we
previously established kalid as An
Origin point for these modern dragons so
for the ice dragons to be here surely
they must have initially migrated here
from kalid now obviously they could have
just flown from kalid to the icy
mountain tops but I remember early
theories that posited that a land bridge
might have once existed between kalid
and the mountaintops and that certainly
would have helped with their migration
as the theory goes kalid and the
mountaintops are almost exclusively
where you'll find the Monstrous crows
the giant dogs and most notably the
remains of the Giants these don't really
appear anywhere else and it seems way
more likely to think that there was once
a land bridge here rather than thinking
that they took the long way around the
lands between on foot what happened too
this land mass is unclear but the lands
between itself has experienced many
other geographical upheavals in the past
and losing a land mass to a meteor or
whatnot might also explain the divergent
evolution of the ice dragons compared to
their fire breathing kin also
established in the mountain mountain
tops around this time were the
astrologers who preceded the sorcerers
established themselves in Mountain Toops
that nearly touched the sky and
considered the fire Giants their
neighbors this description comes to us
from The Sword of night and Flame an
heirloom of the caran royal family which
is headed by renala renala was a
prominent astrologer and thus has links
to the mountaintops of the Giants it
might be a stretch to say that she was
actually there in the mountain tops all
those years ago but she did have an
oathsworn Giant and an oathsworn dragon
that can be summoned to fight for her so
I feel like it's safe to say that she's
connected to the place at least at any
rate eventually the fire Giants would
chase the ice dragons from the peak and
claim it for their own then in turn the
zamore an icy race of Warriors would
Ally with the golden order and Ed the
fire Giants this is incidental but later
in the timeline a character called the
snowy Crone pops up she's an old witch
associated with Kara who wielded snowy
Magics that you could argue would have
been derived from the zor's icy
mountaintops the zamore are after all
the only other beings that could use
cold sorceries so perhaps she learned it
from them this snowy Crone eventually
imparted her cold sorceries to ranii and
ranii has clearly taken on such Frost
Magics as a big part of her sorceress
identity now a couple of dragons
actually had a habit of eating glint
Stone Sorcerers and it was from this
diet that they were corrupted not unlike
the other dragons who took on aspects of
their environment one of these dragons
was smarak fought here whose Glenstone
breath incantation reads smarak was
Devourer of sorcerers and over time his
body became corrupted by their glint
Stones another such dragon is fought
here defending Rani in both of her major
quest locations this is a jeweler and
she drops a cold infused sorcery that is
representative of her Knighthood and it
reads adula A Devourer of sorcerers was
bested by Rani and subsequently swore a
nightly oath to her Dark Moon this this
suggests conflict between the early
Sorcerers and dragons and this tendency
for there to be conflict helps to
explain why rala might have gained an
oathsworn dragon out of these conflicts
and just like her mother before her
Ronnie also had an oathsworn Dragon of
her own adula adula reveals to us the
mechanism behind this oath Ronnie bested
adula in battle perhaps earning aul's la
loyalty and respect a trend that
actually continues later on with some
other ancient dragons that would attack
LEL but we'll get into that soon the
only living ice dragon we meet is
Borealis the freezing fog who remains
upon the mountaintops and yet the item
most closely associated with him is
actually found all the way back in the
temple quarter of Leonia it is the ice
rind Hatchet and its description reads a
hatchet with a frost coated blade one of
several gifts given by Castle soul in
the distant North known as freezing fog
the blade is thought to be a dragon's
scale indeed this is the dragon scale of
Borealis because just as the scale is
known as freezing fog Borealis also has
the words freezing fog as his namesake
when you fight him apparently this scale
was retrieved by boris's Neighbors at
Castle Saul who then gave it as a gift
presumably to the lonians since it is
found near their Temple quarter
obviously such a gift would have been
given to facilitate relations between
the two lands and as we established
earlier with Sorcerers like the snow
witch and renala there is grounds to
believe that these two places would have
had a connection in the past these days
though Castle soul is currently still a
mystery to us and without knowing their
political alignments it's hard to know
for sure why they gifted Leonia with the
scale and other gifts as well that said
there is a phantom in Castle Soul who
hails Lord mola in his dialogue thus
it's possible that Micha was Lord of
Castle soul and that Mika was giving
gifts to Leonia and there is evidence
that Mika had friendly relations with
the carens at least most notably in
version 1.0 of Elden ring Loretta's
armor instead belonged to cut enemies
called ARA Sentinels who served Mika but
who actually hailed from Ral lucaria to
quote their cut description these
Enchanted Knights once belonged to the
caran Royal Family but were later gifted
to Mika thus perhaps Mika potential Lord
of Castle Soul gifted the Rial lucari
the ice rind Hatchet and several other
gifts besides in return for all the
knights that he had gained from them
again this is all just speculation but
this is the best theory I've got on the
relationship between these two lands and
why the ice rind Hatchet is found in
Leonia on the same Plateau as Castle
soul is the Cave of the for laor and
it's a unique little cave guarded by
great worm theodoric theodoric is a
magma worm a land-bound dragon that
looks more like a giant lizard than a
dragon he's in this form thanks to the
act of dragon communion a primal ritual
that involves consuming a dragon's heart
to become a dragon didn't work out so
well for him but his scale sword at
least resembles a dragon's jaw and the
weapon suggests that Dragon communion is
a grave transgression for which the
magma worms were cursed to crawl the
Earth upon their bellies Shadows of
their former selves if they were cursed
to be this Way by any entity I'd suggest
it was the greater will who we know
favored the ancient dragons long ago and
to be clear only the English description
says they were cursed the Japanese
description is nowhere near as damning
simply saying that the heroes have ER
and that their land crawling form is the
end result to me it sounds more like
these people were simply fools to think
that they could achieve such a
metamorphosis it goes against the rules
of nature especially if you're trying to
transform into a being like an ancient
dragon who were graced by the greater
will in a bygone age and I think more
than it being a curse I think this is
more of an example of hubris backfiring
for each and every one of these
partakers of dragon
communion the magma worm's scale sword
States that these land-bound Dragons
Were Once human Heroes but that's only
half true for theodoric who was a hero
but who wasn't human he was actually a
troll his incantation theodoric's magma
states that the name of the ancient
troll Warrior theodoric lives on as a
hero of the war against the Giants
actually maybe his troll Heritage
explains why his magma world worm form
is so much tougher than the others it
has so much HP that fun fact you can
actually lure a land octopus to help you
with this fight instead and I think
that's the intended way because this guy
is tough what's also fascinating about
this guy is that he was specifically a
hero of the war against the Giants a
battle that many of his fellow trolls
participated in betraying their giant
ancestors and fighting alongside the
golden order now I assume theodoric was
still a troll at this stage and not a
magma Worm but whatever the case you
could definitely speculate that he is
still loyal to the golden order even now
even here after his metamorphosis I
argue this because of his placement
outside the cave of the for laor which
has an end boss wielding a legendary
Armament the golden order Greatsword one
of rigan's own weapons the leonine
misbegotten themselves are curious as
well with internal files calling them
children of rigan but that's a whole
another topic unique to this cave also
is that right inside there's a fire
breathing dragon dead and half intmed
within the ice for this type of dragon
to be preserved in this place might
support what I speculated on earlier
which is that gr's fire breathing
children must have come up here to
settle on the Peaks before becoming ice
dragons and it might also support the
theory that renala acquired an oathsworn
fire breathing dragon just like this one
early in the days when they settled here
alongside the astrologers or maybe it's
just here because a Dragon Hunter is
right outside and I say Dragon Hunter
because if even though the dragonhearted
like theodoric aspired to become Dragons
by consuming their hearts that doesn't
mean that they respected their lives a
phantom can even be found saying I'm dry
dry as a bone full Dragon Surrender Your
strength let me Feast on your heart as
for the hearts of these dragons
themselves they are riddled with gravel
Stone you'll recall gravel Stones were
the scales of the ancient dragons making
it somewhat ironic that the Mortal
dragons actually do have these same
scales just within their hearts not on
their flesh as such their hearts which
are clearly imbued with some ancient
dragon immortality are still alive and
beating according to the description and
so when you consume these hearts in what
is absolutely a sacrificial ritual the
especially considering the heart is
still alive you're actually consuming
gravel Stone ingesting the key
components of the ancient dragons via
the hearts of their mortal kin it's
pretty metal indeed when you partake in
Dragon communion with the heart at the
dragon communion altars you're doing so
right in front of a dead ancient dragon
not in front of a mortal one thus you
really are striving to be like the
Ancients churches were built upon the
corpses of these undying beings who
became likely unwilling conduits for
countless dragonhearted Heroes who
wished to channel the power of dragons
finally the dragon communion seal it's
formless because it's made of Dragon
Blood and even though it's a seal Dragon
communion is too Primal in nature for
the term incantation to be appropriate
thus this seal scales incantations with
one's Arcane attribute so yeah it's no
wonder that all of the dragonhearted are
considered to be so
depraved you must not forget though
those who partake in Dragon communion
will one day shed their Humanity their
hunger for Dragon their
yearning only worsens until the
floodgates
burst unleashing eternal torment the
strength of a mighty
Dragon
magnificent but deadly it's no surprise
that Dragon communion is
ruinous this is Ura who you first meet
in Lim grave and nearby beside the
dragon burnt ruins is the Mortal Dragon
agil agil frequents this place coming to
burn the Mindless Nobles and their
Effigies here which is exactly what the
Nobles want after death most in the
lands between crave a proper her tree
burial but now in lie of that perhaps
the dead gazed at the Skies over the
lakes of lim grave praying that the
dragon's Flames would burn them to Ash
they want this kind of release from life
if you get Ura to assist you you in
taking out agal then it's possible to
get him to say
this that was my first dragon hunting
quite some time PA up with a hote head
like
you it was just like old times so Ura
was previously a Dragon Hunter which
helps to explain his familiarity with
communion and since being paired up with
a hote head like you was just like old
times that means he must have once had a
companion the most likely candidate for
this is elanora a drake Knight that Ura
tracks all the way to the Altus Plateau
only to plead with them on a very
personal
level
please
elanora yield to the CES blood no longer
do not stain the immaculacy of your
sword your
flesh
you're
fire the precious little we know about
elanora stems mostly from her Drake
Knight armor which is crafted from
dragonwing membranes and features The
Spoils of a dragon catch as an emblem of
Pride as both Dragon Hunter and partaker
of communion from birth Drake Knights
speak not a word they spend their lives
pursuing the strength of dragons for its
Sublime Beauty and inspiration of a
therefore while the Drake Knights have
more reverence of dragons they are still
partakers of communion thus as they
consume more Hearts their eyes become
yellow and slitted and inevitably they
have a fate waiting for them as a magma
worm so given all you've heard about
communion is it really any surprise that
there would be a dragon named the dragon
communion Revenger
this is exis who guards the decrepit
Temple of communion in kalid attempting
to prevent this abhorent act of dragon
communion via sheer will and hatred for
exis had The Misfortune of taking on the
Scarlet rot as his aspect something that
has clearly taken a toll on him but
according to his incantation exi Dragon
communion Revenger did not forget his
hatred even as he succumbed to the
Scarlet rot so exis at least has a very
good reason for attacking you as he's
preventing access to the nearby altar of
dragon communion but speaking of Dragons
Who attack humans let's turn our
attention to the ancient dragons who
would one day attack the city of lell
these ancient dragons attacked with all
their might bringing with them grandac
an ancient dragon who is the largest
dragon in the game who reigned Calamity
down upon the Royal Capital with such
force that this marks the only time in
historical record that L Del's walls had
fallen thus began lel's war against the
ancient
Dragons It's hard to know for for sure
why the ancient dragons attacked LEL if
you want to go full tinf foil hat and
tie it to our earlier speculations then
you might say that it's because they
finally realized their God had fled here
and become the Earth tree or something
but that might be stretching it that
said they probably did come here because
of the her tree after all according to
the protection of the earth tree
incantations in the beginning everything
was in opposition to the Earth tree and
the ancient dragons were probably no
exception so it was that the ancient
dragons fell upon LEL their forces
consisting of at least three dragons
that we know of lancs and her red
lightning glaive fortox and his twin
pillars of red lightning and grx a
gargantuan Dragon wielding a physical
weapon actually a decision that seems
unique to them this is the B VA of grand
sax a weapon that's actually mirrored in
places Sax's fight against us here it's
unclear whether places sax is echoing
Grand sax or if Grand sax is echoing
places sax but the fact that grandx
shares a weapon with places sax and the
fact that grand sax is so large
certainly makes me think that grandx is
the closest thing the ancient dragons
might have had to a lord at the time of
their attack upon lell at any rate but
this weapon would eventually fall from
their grasp as the great grand sax was
slain their Stone body and weapon
becoming this permanent Landmark Within
lel's Walls according to lightning
Spears description Godwin the golden
defeated the ancient dragon fortox known
as the mightiest Boulder Stone assumedly
Godwin could have executed fortox here
or perhaps compelled fortox to swear an
oath to him just like renala and Ronnie
once did but instead he befriended his
Fallen Foe and as a result fortox would
be loyal so loyal that fortox would
eventually go beyond to fight against
the death that would take his companion
becoming a lich Dragon his aspect
Afflicted with death itself so to recap
when Godwin was murdered on the night of
black knives the Rune of death was
carved into his being destroying his
soul but not his body and so it was that
his body spawned death rot fragments of
the Rune of death that spreads its
influence throughout the lands between
spawning the Visage of the prince of
death who was Godwin in its wake and
while Godwin does seem like a lost cause
for ax fought against the death within
him nonetheless so it is that forx
occupies a deathbed Dream Within his
friend fighting this impossible fight
against the corrupting influence of the
Rune of death which has now corrupted
fortox but I still don't think that
fortox has been completely corrupted
when you fight against fortox here you
actually do so to bring about the age of
those who live in death and consider
considering fortox fights against you
you could speculate that fortox is still
vly opposed to death and those who live
within death even now check out this
video for more on that anyway so it
should come as no surprise that this
friendship between Godwin and fortox was
seen as significant in lell when fortox
was first defeated this moment of
friendship was so significant that it
would make allies of all the ancient
dragons and give rise to the Ancient
Dragon Cult in the capital city it seems
the Ancient Dragon Cult was born out of
a desire to defend the Earth tree as
stated by the malformed dragon set after
the great ancient dragon grx attacked
the tree Sentinels had an epiphany the
only way to truly protect the ER tree
was to become dragons themselves so it
was that these regular tree Sentinels
became draconic tree Sentinels as a fun
side note the 1.0 description of the
malformed Dragon set instead talks about
a dragon worshipper named Nal who I
speculate is this individual defending
malth in faram maula his set once read
once a dragon worshipper from the
capital it's said that he pulverized his
golden armor with his bare hands in a
fit of religious fervor covering it in
his own blood as he reshaped it in the
likeness of a dragon but anyway in the
final version of the game there's more
than one draconic tree Sentinel and they
wield armaments whittel from Dragon
claws so that they could better honor
the ancient dragons in their worship
without resorting to the Primal Act of
dragon communion and conveniently for
them it was found that Dragon worship
didn't clash with belief in the Earth
tree the gravelstone seal says as much
stating after all this seal and
lightning itself are both imbued with
gold and this goes beyond just color the
ancient dragons were originally a part
of the greater Will's plan back in faram
maula and their golden scales reflect
that and after the dragon war these
ancients became a part of the greater
Will's plan once more albeit in a more
subservient role than in their previous
age one thing that's kind of difficult
to reconcile with the Dragon Cult is the
fact that their prayer books cookbooks
spells and even a draconic tree Sentinel
can be found in Far amula special thanks
to V limit on YouTube for making me
aware of this the ancient dragon war in
Lanell would have surely happened after
faram maula's age had passed so how did
all of this get up there
either faram maula became skybound much
later in the timeline than I thought or
perhaps Dragon cultists simply traveled
up to Fula with these relics somehow and
I think this second theory is much more
likely because in an earlier version of
the game Fula was actually called the
storm eerie and was and I quote a place
that only dragons can reach this reminds
me a lot of arch Dragon Peak in Dark
Souls 3 which could only be accessed
through a sort of draconic meditation so
perhaps Fula was once planned to be
accessed in a similar way for all we
know it could still be cannon that those
in tune with dragons are spirited up
here for instance some banished Knights
certainly found a way up here and they
have dragons cresting their helmet and
this helmet once described how they
sought the storm eie presumably through
revering dragons therefore I feel like
remnants of characters being spirited up
here due to their association with
Dragons is a bit of a hold over from a
past version of the game that still
exists in the current version and while
we don't get spirited up in the current
game by becoming a dragon we are
certainly spirited up here this
teleportation occurs when you sacrifice
melan or yourself in the frenzy ending
now the mechanism behind this is kind of
unclear but there is sort of a prophecy
that helps to explain it melan's blade
of calling reads the one who walks
alongside flame shall one day meet the
road of destined death so whether you
walk alongside melanina the kindling
maiden or the god of frenzied Flame or
your Alexander tempering yourself in the
Flames of G
and the Giants Forge you're going to
make it up here one way or another and
meet the road of destined death speaking
of which this also explains why beral is
up here according to his Beast champion
armor his Maiden threw herself into the
fire just like melan does for us which
is what gets us up here and he too also
has a fate that ends with destined death
just like we do so there's definitely
some sort of fate associated with
destined death that is spiriting us up
here I think that's for sure and to
explain most others up here in faram
moula well again I personally think that
they were likely spirited up thanks to
their draconic nature as explained by
the cut content from that earlier
version of Elden ring for all the humans
who desired to commune with Dragons
there was one Dragon who actually
communed with humans lancs lanc was the
sister of fortox and while you fight her
as a dragon in game long ago she took
the form of a human to better commune
with the Dragon Knights as a priestess
of the Ancient Dragon Cult of lell the
fact that she was able to take human
form is pretty amazing this is almost a
reflection of dragon communion but
instead of changing form and communing
with Dragons she's changing form to
better commune with humans a part of
this communion apparently was love and
according to Dragon Bolt blessing only
those loved by dragons can survive the
ordeal of cladding their bodies in
lightninging and of all the knights vik
the dragon spear was the one lancs loved
the most fittingly vik's Dragon Bolt is
unique in that it clads him and his
spear in red lightning the signature
weapon of the ancient dragons reserved
up until this point for the beastmen who
served them in Antiquity this also marks
VI as a dragon cultist therefore it's
kind of crazy to think that a dragon
cultist almost became Elden Lord
something that surely would have had
implications for the age that would
follow you know if vik was to take the
throne this must have made it all the
more painful painful for many when vik
suddenly disappeared traveling below
lell to visit the three fingers where he
was burned by their frenzy armor and all
knowing that he was a dragon cultist
certainly helps to explain how he got
down here the fact that he was surely
this highly regarded member of lanell's
Dragon Cult you'd think would open doors
for him within the city so vik likely
could have made the trip down here
easily despite the existence of the
three fingers being sacrilegious to the
order up above we get little information
on why vik made this trip but in the end
we eventually find him imprisoned within
a ever jail and whether this
imprisonment is self-imposed or not also
remains a bit of a mystery but anyway
back to lancs who loved vik the most
interesting thing here with her I think
isn't just the fact that we've learned
that dragons can turn into humans it's
the fact that dragons can love perhaps
this love and Powerful emotion is part
of what makes them so loyal we see many
becoming oath sworn and then forac for
example going so far as to sacrifice
himself entirely for his friend and it's
this fact that makes the Elden Lord
places Sax's abandonment by his God all
the more tragic for their God would
never return and eventually a tarnished
would find their way Beyond Time putting
an end to the dragon lord and hu their
remembrance into the Earth tree in the
end All That Remains is plous Sax's ruin
the dying whales of the Dragon Lord who
once dwell eternally Beyond
Time thank you for watching ing but
before I go do you want some Elden ring
wall art to Adorn your walls well
display as you covered in this video
because they're back helping to support
more Elden ring lore content for a
limited time only they are giving you
these deals on screen to pick up some
displates in the next few weeks Link in
the description so the choice is yours
you can literally get official Elden
ring art to Adorn your walls for example
this shot of Godfrey and vik look
absolutely stunning uh but then you can
also get some Elden ring inspired pieces
from my store if you like for example
this is Guardian Of Moonlight which
features a dragon defending a Moonlight
sword from nightly Intruders or you
could pick up early days which gives off
some Elden ring vibes from back before
the game was even released if you were
around then or if you're a fan of from
software games in general you could go
and pick up the painted world with Demon
Souls Dark Souls bloodborne SEO and
Elden ring all condensed into one world
it'll take you hours of scrutiny to
discover all of the references that
we've hidden in here as I've said so
many times before these prints are made
of metal they're easy to hang and
somehow they achieve this gorgeous color
depth and accuracy that exceeds most of
the traditional prints that I've sampled
again links in the description and thank
you for watching it feels good to be
back doing Elden ring law and my goal
now is to wrap up everything I can
before the Elden ring DLC drops so there
should be some good times ahead you know
bringing in the New Year as well before
I go earlier I shouted out Loki's theory
on the nameless God as I call them and
I'd again like to remind you to go ins
support Loki and check out their other
law content for yourself as well and if
you have any other suggestions for other
content creators whose theories you'd
like to see cited in future law videos
please let me know and I'll do my best
to do that special thanks also to
misspap for doing an incredible edit of
this video the footage looks amazing and
it's incredible that he can get this
much quality footage even for a video
that is an hour and a half long so I
hope that fact really helps you guys
watch the content and engage with it
thank you again for watching and I'll
see you in the next L
video